and upcoming part of the show will be
kind of gender identity and discussing
that did you have feelings when you know
we're hearing about Caitlyn Jenner no I
thought about it for sure which is like
what do I want to James it's like it's
just something that I would do well I
think that a lot of people have just
kind of raised questions about that
since I you know play in men's and
women's wear and I kind of make sand and
stuff like that and you know I just
think there was an important
conversation to have I think what the
reality shows it's really really really
important that you're taking away
something from every single episode
because like why else would you be
watching someone live their life on
television if you're not learning
something and and I really wanted to do
that with what this show is for people
to learn people are so quick to judge
where do you find your confidence from
where does that come from I just really
am happy just to live live my life the
way that I want to live it and let my
truth and that gives me confidence every
day to go out in the world and kind of
you know do me I think doing me just you
know makes me happy and and just you
know brings out all of my confidence and
I think that everyone should should be
able to do that you should always be
able to live your life fearless and
carefree and it shouldn't matter